let's not turn to an issue that's come
up in the last 48 hours senator Sanders
see none reported yesterday that and
senator Sanders senator Warren confirmed
in a statement that in 2018 you told her
that you did not believe that a woman
could win the election why did you say
that well as a matter of fact I didn't
say oh and I don't want to waste a whole
lot of time on this because this is what
Donald Trump and maybe some of the media
want anybody knows me knows that it's
incomprehensible that I would think that
a woman could not be President of the
United States go to youtube today
there's some video of that of me 30
years ago talking about how a woman
could become president of the United
States in 2015 I deferred in fact the
Senate Awards was a movement to draft
senator Warren to run for president and
you know what I said stay back senator
Warren decided not to run and I did I
did run afterwards Hillary Clinton won
the popular vote by three million votes
how could anybody in a million years not
believe that a woman could become
president of the United States and let
me be very clear if any of the women on
this stage or any of the men on this
stage win the nomination I hope that's
not the case I hope it's me but if they
do I will do everything in my power to
make sure that they are elected in order
to defeat the most dangerous president
in the history of our country so senator
Sanders you're saying that you never
told senator Warren that a woman could
not win the election that is correct
why'd you ask that again he literally
told you in his answer senator Warren
what did you think when senators Andrew
Sanders told you a woman could not win
the election No oh wow CNN doing at the
same time can you be surprised all right
laughing we don't cover a lot of
politics here Oh didn't we speaking
because I feel like most of the time
when I see political commentary a lot of
it's based off incomplete information we
don't have a lot of the behind the
scenes stuff we don't really understand
the entirety of what's happening so I
can't make sense of this decision-making
and why things are happening so for me
it's just hard to talk on it and offer
you guys any real input
I don't understand what I can tell you
is that I think mainstream media is
absolutely garbage garbage I'm not even
in this cliff put yourself in the mirror
do this [ __ ] alone I'm already done with
this I looked into the claim apparently
a staffer of Warren told her sander said
this she even here directly and for this
reporter this one who's like handling
the debate her to sit there and ask that
question have him denied once then
reiterate that question which is like a
you can't win in that kind of question
she's already denied it twice and then
for you to ask the woman got what was it
like when he hit you he just said he hit
her twice and if she can't firsthand
admit that that's what happened why are
you saying it as if it's a matter of
fact that's what bothers me
and you know CNN and the DNC in general
have done a great job a pretty much run
to dismantle Bernie Sanders campaigns at
every point they have for Bernie Sanders
to still be part of the DNC to me is a
goddamn show consider what they did to
him in 2016 the way they stole that from
him when he was supposed to be the
Democratic nominee I'm so over
mainstream politics to me I've become
apathetic to it because it's just such a
lack of integrity such a lack of moral
character for these people to be paid so
much money for them to steal our tax
dollars for them to get up there every
single time and make a mockery of
democracy is just unbelievable to me I
cannot believe that we fund this kind of
garbage and it's a joke it's a goddamn
joke although whether you're a Democrat
a Republican is a joke all the way from
the trashes fan in the county of garbage
Joe what did she answer she said I did
do it she did say that that's what she
says
at the end of it they're supposed to do
a handshake and she won't shake his hand
she gets mad and she's like you called
me a liar on national TV blah blah blah
to me it's unbelievable though in order
to lead our country we elect the people
who seem to have the least amount of
moral character I mean I could go on my
street and find people with more
integrity than most of those people on
that pan and I'm supposed to take time
on my day to try to surmise what kind of
kid you miss me with that
not interested everyone's so concerned
with trying to beat Trump that they
don't come they don't care if they elect
a garbage person they don't care what
that person has to do to get there and
beat them they don't care and I'm like
that's the problem with this continent
we've lost sight of the importance of
having character and integrity and I'm
just so sick of trying to choose a
lesser of two evils to choose the one
who's going to lie to me the least how
about I choose someone who's gonna tell
the truth but it just doesn't seem
possible man
and then the media sources that we're
supposed to trust in order to
disseminate that information or even
more unreliable and are all bought and
paid for it's garbage it's absolute
garbage and YouTube marks them as
trusted sources for us to get our knees
from on YouTube it's a joke it's a joke
who asks that kind of question twice no
three times thrice well I'll let you go
man I'm doing this dream let me go I
drop out of this subject a long-ass time
ago the minute he said I was like
brother I'm not even gonna uh this
there's so much I could say but why why
would I even engage in that why would I
why would why would I even start with
this love no no and people get mad at me
when I'm like I don't want to vote you
don't want Democrats are living in the
past Trump is gonna win again and I
can't wait to see you guys [ __ ] fail
I can't wait now because I like Trump or
his policies or his ideas but because
you guys are absolute trash you're trash
you're trash
you guys are digging your own holes you
guys are garbage man anyways I'm done
with this you don't know I really felt
like his rebuttal to her accusation was
perfect in terms of saying that you know
I supported Hillary when she won the
nomination stole but we'll save one you
know she had the popular vote so I
thought his rebuttal was poignant you
know and I find it very odd that this
was said to Warren too
years ago right and she just sat on it
for like two and a half years she just
sat on this big revelation about Bernie
being some kind of misogynistic person
behind closed doors and then the day
before the debate her team leaks it and
CNN just gives her softball for her to
hit for her to hit her home run and just
and know she just expects nobody to
think that this is extremely staged that
question the way it was framed looked
staged her response to how perfectly
mean it was looks staged you know the
reporter made it sound like oh this just
came to us an hour ago we just found out
that you said this Bernie
everything looked super staged and I'm
like how dumb do you think we are to me
what's almost as insulting as the lack
of morals on display was how dumb they
thought the viewers were it just seems
like politicians are still stuck in the
past they still use tactics from way
back in the day thinking and it's gonna
sway us and it is just so disappointing
that I'm not surprised that young people
are so apathetic in regards to politics
I think this will keep going until we
revamp our system because honestly the
way things are set up right now
[Music]